ولو بتلتفت اليوم الخلف ابو بدر في
2019 نتكلم على ثلاث اربع سنوات صارت في
السعوديه ابغاك تذكر لي اكثر جهازين
حكوميه كان لوجودها اثر واضح على نجاحكم
وابغاك تذكر لي اكثر الجهتين تعتقد انه في
مساحه لتطوير عملهم حتى يمكن رواد الاعمال
بشكل اكثر من زاويه تجربه فلور لازم يصير
في توائم اكثر ما بين الجهات الحكوميه
تجاه تحقيق الرؤيه يعني اليوم الرؤيه تلقي
باهدافها على جميع جهات على جميع جهات
والمفروض هذه الاهداف كلها تصب فيه
الاهداف العامه مالت الرؤيه الواقع عنا في
بعض الجهات اهدافها تتضارب مع الاخت مثل
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من الاذاعه ثمانيه وانا عمر
الجريسي استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال
وقاده الراي وسولف معهم مع المستجدات
ومستدفات رؤيه السعوديه عشرين ثلاثين ضيف
حلقه اليوم هو الاستاذ عبد العزيز
اللوغاني المؤسس والرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
فلاون عبد العزيز عنده تجربه ثريه وطويله
في رياده الاعمال من من الشخصيات القليله
في المنطقه العربيه اللي اسست شركتين وصلت
مبيعاتها
لعشرات او مئات الملايين الاولى كانت
تجربه طلبات والثانيه هي تجربه فلور الحلو
في التجربتين وهذا اللي لابسنا احنا في
سقراط انه واحده منهم قبل الرؤيه والثانيه
بعد الرؤيه فاستخدمنا هالتجربتين للتعرف
على ايش اللي اختلف وتحول في منظومه
الاعمال وفي بيئه الاستثمار وفي اجراءات
دخول المستثمرين للسوق السعودي فاتكلمنا
بشكل سريع عن تجربه طلبات ايش كان المشهد
رياده الاعمال في ذلك الوقت بعدين دخلنا
على تج
وبعدها توسعنا شوي في بيئه رياده الاعمال
في الخليج ضيفه كان مسؤول حكومي في فتره
معينه فسالناه ليش هذه التجربه وهذه
الخبره منعكست على السوق الكويتي اللي كان
هو شغال فيه رغم تميز الكفاءات هناك سالته
عن السوق السعودي من اكثر جهتين حكوميه
ساهمت في نجاحها ومين اكثر جهتين حكوميه
يتوقع ويتمنى منها التطوير اكثر لتمكين
رواد الاعمال ما دخلنا كثير في تفاصيل
نموذج العمل لانه بهذا تركيز سقرار وانما
كانت تركيز هو على ايش اللي اختلف في مشهد
بيئه ورياده الاعمال وفي الاخير ختمنا
بالفتره الجايه هو يرى ان الفتره الجايه
حتكون صعبه على رياده الاعمال اللي هي سنه
23 بسبب المستجدات الاقتصاديه لكن عنده
توصيات او مقترحات لرواد الاعمال في هذا
المجال فاتركم مع الحوار حياك الله ابو
بدر شرفتنا ونورتنا الله الله يحفظك يا رب
يا مرحبا انا ابو بدر جزء من البحث
يعني والاستقصاء حولك
لاحظت معلومه اثنين ذكروها واحد صديق واحد
زميل عمل كلهم قالوا يعني اسال عن الموضوع
دق العود الصباح
الغريب الغريب ما هو في مشهد هوايه العود
فيها شوي بس الاغرب هو موضوع ارتباطها
بالصباح
وارتباطها في نمط حياتك مستمره حتى في
احلك الازمات يعني وبعدين يقول حتى في
يعني واحد يعني فتره عصيبه على الشركه يدق
علينا الصباح ولا يكلم الصباح يدق عود
يعني صديقك يقول انه احيانا اصحى الصباح
الاقي الساعه سته مرسل لي مقطوعه يبارك لي
في يوم ميلادي مثلا وش قصتك مع العود في
الصباح انا سلمت الله اقوم استيقظ عاده
العب رياضه اركض بشكل يومي هذا يمكن يوم
واحد بالاسبوع
ومن يشق النور عاد العيال يقوم
بدر يعني تجهيز المدرسه وبعدين اذا العمل
احنا يبلش عندنا الساعه تسع انا غالبا ما
اكون موجود الساعه ثمانيه
وهذه اول نص ساعه من اليوم امارس احد
الهوايات اللي عندي اللي هو اعزف العود
وبالنسبه لي يعني
الصبح
فاتمرن وطبعا هذه بالايام اللي اكون فيها
بمكتب نص الوقت انا خارج المكتب صراحه بس
بالايام يكون موجود فيها فعلا اعزف لانه
بالنسبه لي يا اخي الموسيقى فعلا تؤنس وحش
الكائن
وفي ناس يسوون يوجا عدل والثاني يسوي شويه
تنويم مغناطيسي مش عارف شنو وفي ناس تقرا
قران اقرا قران احيانا بس في عنصر عندي هو
الموسيقى
من سلمك الله
اعزف من عشر سنوات تقريبا بس حبي الموسيقى
من زمان صراحه
يعني عاده ارتبط العود
بالمساء بالامسيات
بالسمر في يعني تقريبا مرتبطه في المساء
يعني انا ما حتى اقعد احاول اتخيل مشهد
واحد في الصباح غريبه يمكن اقربها لك لا
رحت مطعم
وتريقت فطرت بمكان غالبا ما راح تسمع يمكن
فيروز صح صح
او قالبها بس الفكره وحده اعتقد انك يعني
تستيقظ على قران تسمع شيء حلو ومفيد لعقلك
ويمكن بعدها تعزف موسيقى
اعتقد الفكره واحده
احنا ابو بدر سعداء باستضافتك اليوم بصفتك
مؤسس لعده شركات ناشئه وعندك تجارب في
القطاع الاعمال في قطاع الاستثمار بالنسبه
لنا احنا في سقراط
كمشروع يهدف لتوثيق الرؤيه والتحول نعيشه
اكثر شيء فانتظرنا وحمسنا القصه هي انها
مقسومه على جزئين خلنا نقول تجربه تاسيس
طلبات وهذه كانت قبل الرؤيه ومنها دخلت
شويه للسوق السعودي وعشت تجربه الدخول
السوق السعودي بعدين تجربه فلورت اللي هي
بعد سنه من من انطلاق الرؤيه وعاصرت فيها
التغير اللي صار في بيئه الاستثمار
ومنظومه الاعمال
بعد الرؤيه فانت بالنسبه لنا شاهد على
التحول من واقع او من زاويه المستثمر
وبنفس الوقت انت مريت باكثر من تجربه في
قطاع الاعمال ودعم المنشات المتوسطه فبرضه
يمكن نسولف في اخر حلقه على المشهد في
الخليج
والتفاوت والتنافس اللي صاير بين الرياض
دبي بقيت دول الخليج قطاع التجاره
الكترونيه
نبدا من طلبات ونعرف ايش قصتها وكيف كانت
تجربه الدخول للسوق السعودي ايام طلبات
وبعدها ندخل على
سلمت الله بذاك الوقت خلنا يعني قبل طلبات
خلنا بنفس الزمان
نتذكر ونستذكر شنو السعوديه كانت قبل
الرؤيه صح فبذاك الوقت تقريبا حجم
الاقتصاد 600 ملي اي ما يعادل يمكن عشرين
الى 25% من حجم اقتصاد العالم العربي ذلك
الوقت
معدل الانترنت
كان اقل من خمسين بالمئه في السعوديه 43%
اتوقع نعم
طبعا الهواتف الذكيه كانت مو متواجده اصلا
بذاك الوقت
كبيئه تشريعيه داخل الدوله
اقرب ما يكون كذلك تعاملنا مع الجهات
الرقابيه هو لانجاز المعاملات الحكوميه
فقط
ومتى ما الله لا يقول خالفت شيء كان شرط
المرور موجود على طول
[موسيقى]
العقاب متوفر
السعوديه اللي هو الاجهزه
الرقابيه مثل هيئه الاتصالات موجوده
[موسيقى]
القطاع اللوجستي في السعوديه
للتجاره الالكترونيه ما كان موجود
ما تشوف المدفوعات الرقميه
فعدى يمكن مدى بذاك الوقت ما كان في ادوات
اخرى للمدفوعات الرقميه
تتكلم عن
البيئه بيئه رياده الاعمال هل كان في
انتماء ولا لا هل كان في مجتمع رواد اعمال
ولا لا محدود جدا قالوا احنا اثنين اصلا
بذاك الوقت بتشوف
مميزات اللي موجوده والدعم اللي موجود من
الدوله كذلك محدود جدا يكاد اصلا ما يكون
موجود
معدل التجاره الالكترونيه لما تبحث فيه
تشوف هذه البنيه التحتيه اللي قلنا عنها
ما في انترنت كثير الانترنت يمكن حتى لو
كان متواجد كان غالي وسرعته قليله شبكه
الاتصالات شركات الاتصالات بذاك الوقت
شبكاتها متواضعه ما كانت في مثل ما هي
عليه الان المدفوعات الرقميه ما في شركات
توصيل اصلا كانت الناس لما تشتغل فقط تطلب
اونلاين ترى ما في خدمه التوصيل التوصيل
هو عن طريق المتجر او الطرف اللي انت
تتعامل معه
لذلك كان معدل التجاره الالكترونيه
لا يتجاوز صفر فاصله اثنين بالمئه
يعني شفت السعوديه وحجمها احنا قلنا 20
الى 25% من اقتصاد الوطن العربي وتقريبا
50% من اقتصاد الخليج هذا
محصور فقط على الصناعات التقليديه على
السوق التقليدي اللي هو
تقارنه في شنو اللي موجود عبر الانترنت
كتجاره الالكترونيه كان ماي ما يمثل نفس
النسبه فالنسبه وتناسب هي اضعف بكثير كثير
كثير لذلك كان تجربه الناس في السوق
السعودي
عن طريق الانترنت
باستثناء اللهم بعد القطاعات يمكن اهمها
هو السفر يعني حجز الاوتيلات والتذاكر
السفر عدا ذلك ترى ما كان يمثل نفس السوق
التقليدي او التجزئه اللي موجود تمام فهذه
البيئه اللي احنا دخلنا عليها ايام طلبات
بالخير بمشاري لومير كان عندنا تعاون كذلك
مع احد الاطرافني فهذه البيئه اللي موجود
عليها انت الان حق طلبات
شنو المنافسه هيكل السوق
ما في سوق
وما في سوق انا اقول لك كان في شركه واحده
اسمها اطلب واللي هي كانت في البحرين هي
اللي تشتغل في السعوديه بس خلنا ابو بدر
عشان اللي مو متابع القصه ناخذ كذا لمحه
سريعه على طلبات وايش كان نموذجها بداته
في الكويت بعدين دخلتوا السوق السعودي لو
تكلمت على تسلسل زمني بحمل احداث خصوصا
اللي لفت نظري انا كنت اعتقد بس في بس انت
حتى طلبات انت مو المؤسس الاول لها صحيح
انت اشتريت او استثمرت صحيح وبعدين توليت
قيادتها وهذا ملفت النظر انه تجربتين اللي
انت وصلتها لمبيعات مليونيه كلها مو انت
المؤسس لها مفهوم فطلبات بالفعل كان في
بعض الاصدقاء شغالين عليها وانا بشكل
موازي كنت شغال على موقع للصيدليات
ما مشي الحال معي بعد فتره انضميت
واستثمرت مع الاخوه وبعدين اخذنا احنا
تقريبا 2006 ولا
2008 2007 اوكي لان الشباب بلشوا قبلي
بسنه سنتين
واستثمرنا
واعتقد كنا محظوظين السوق بذاك الوقت كان
خصب
فمقارنه خلينا نقول في المملكه لو تشوف
الكويت يمكن البنيه التحتيه للتجاره
الالكترونيه
كانت يمكن اخصب وافضل ذاك الوقت
لعده اسباب اهمها البنى التحتيه
فتوسعنا كان في السعوديه كان عبر افران
شايز كان للحين ما في فلوس
ذاك الوقت يعني افضل مصدر ولا في افضل
مصدر للتمويل هو مبيعاتك
وبالفعل هو الاقل كلفه لكن
ديناميكيه وتفكير رائد الاعمال بذاك الوقت
دائما مرتبطه بالربحيه
بينما الان الوضع مختلف
فاشتغلنا عبر بكل بساطه طلبات مطاعمه صح
صحيح هي منصه تعرض منتجات المحلات او
المطاعم اللي
نتشارك معاهم
ويتم الطلب مقابل كل طلب
في رسم معين كنا احنا ناخذه من المطعم
ورسم ناخذه من العميل
ما كان في توصيل كان اذا المطعم ما عنده
توصيل خلاص ما نقدر نشتغل معاه اصلا ليش
لان شركات
ما كان عندها الخدمات اللي اليوم متوفره
مع المطاعم اللي عندها توصيل فقط اوكي هذه
البدايه وكان عبر الواتساب فقط عبر الموقع
الالكتروني
التطبيق ما كان موجود يا تالي اول تطبيق
عملناه كان حق بلاك بيري يعني اذكر
وبعدين عاد التطور التطور في السعوديه كان
عبر كذلك شريكنا
يشتغلون واحنا في دعم فني اداري استراتيجي
لكن ما كنا نشتغل بيتنا الحقيقه بس الملفت
للنظر هو البيئه اللي نشتغل فيها
في بيئه عامه اللي وصفناها قبل شوي وبعدين
في بيئه خاصه في نمط عملنا وشغلنا ما كان
في منافسه كثيره ما في منافسه مو شيء
احيانا يكون شيء زين لان السوق كله لك صح
فلما يكون السوق كله لك
خل ناخذها حبه حبه
الكلفه في العمل
اعلاناتنا اليوم عبر
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي او محركات البحث
كلها كانت ارخص ما كان في تواصل اجتماعي
سامحني
فالبحث اليوم عبر جوجل
كانت الخلفه اقل بكثير من اللي نشوفها
اليوم وبعدين ما كان في ضوابط بنفس ضوابط
انت اليوم تشتغل في مجال معين ما تقدر
تعلن بهالمجال ذاك الوقت كان كاس العالم
انا نحط
شيء مرتبط بكاس العالم اذا الناس ابحثت
عنه تلقانا
ما في منافسه
التكلفه اقل
كعماله مهارات تبي تستقطبها لكن بنفس
الوقت هذه المهارات حلوه
فبنفس الوقت هذه المهارات
انت محتاج اكثر من السوق بوفره لك استقطاب
مهارات
صراحه ممتازه كان يصعب علينا
شركه صغيره شنو اللي يشتغلون
اخلي ارامكو ولا البنوك ولا شركات
الاتصالات وهي عندهم صعب حتى لو يعني
تعطيه الشمس بايد والقمر بيد
المهارات المتوفره كانت اقل
الناس اللي انت حاب تستقطبهم حتى لو من
خارج المملكه
صعب يمكن مستحيل ثقافه البيئه انت عارف
المجتمع شلون شلون تغير يعني خلينا نقول
بالفتره الماضيه فكان في صعوبه حيل في
استقطاب المهارات اللي محتاجينها واجراءات
الحكوميه هل هل مريت بمرحله انك احتاج
تراجع جهات حكوميه في ذيك الفتره محدوده
جدا انا اذكر للامانه غير
الجانب التجاره والتاسيس كان اكثر شيء
لنتواصل مع هيئه الاتصالات يعني هم اللي
ترددنا عليهم اكثر من مره سواء كان حق
تسجيل الدومين
او
يعني تعاملنا محدود مثل ما ذكرت لك من
الجهات الرقابيه والحكومه يكاد يكون محدود
فيه التعاملات
الحكوميه يعني فقط لا غير
حق
الكبيئه يعني مره ثانيه احنا شلون نشتغل
اقناع المطاعم شيء جديد اقناع الناس اصلا
انها تطلب اونلاين شيء جديد فكانت
البدايات معظمها مجاملات اليوم انا اعرف
ابو عبد الحميد واعرف فلان واعرف علان
وبيجاملوني علشان يساعدونا في الشركه بس
كسوق محدود جدا
ناهيك عن ان معدل التجاره الالكترونيه في
المملكه اقل بكثير مقارنه باقرانهم في دول
الخليج والمنطقه عدل فكانت كانت
مو سهله ابدا ابدا مو سهله للبداياتها
وقعدت فيها ثلاث سنوات او اربع سنوات 2010
تخرجت 2010 الله يذكره بالخير محمد
استحوذ على البزنس وهو كمل انا كملت بس
بشكل غير تنفيذي
بحكم الخلفيه اللي انا جاي منها من
الدراسه انا تخصصت في تجاره الالكترونيه
واداره نظم معلومات بعدين اشتغلت في
الاستثمار والملكيات الخاصه وكنت اشتغل
بالسعوديه بعد ذاك الوقت اي نعم فكثير من
الاستثماراتنا كانت في السعوديه ولو بنلخص
ما بين 2007 2010 وش اللي فرق في طلبات
كحجم كعمليات
كاسواق والله
بذاك الوقت كنا نشتغل في الكويت السعوديه
فقط بس كخدمات وتطور المنتج استثمرنا كثير
واعتقد اعتقد غير ان احنا اشتغلنا وحاولنا
نكون قدر المستطاع
اذكياء في توجيه مواردنا اعتقد كنا
محظوظين بالتوقيت ليش لانه صار في تحول
بالعالم
معدل الانترنت في العالم العربي بالكويت
وللسعوديه قام يتطور بشكل ملحوظ قامت
الناس كلها تشتغل
الهواتف الذكيه ونمط استخدامنا وكاسلوكنا
للمستهلك العربي الخليجي تطور حيل
شعوبنا استهلاكيه معظم موظفين
الدوله سواء كان في الكويت السعوديه كثير
منهم سعوديين وكويتيين فياخذ راتب وشيء
جديد يجرب الادخار عندنا كثقافه ما هو شيء
اساسي يا اما المجتمعنا الحمد لله الناس
عايشه كثير منا حياه كريمه فما في ادخار
فالصرف كاستهلاك عالي جدا
الهواتف الذكيه والنقل النوعيه اللي صارت
في شركات الاتصالات بتوفيرها
التطبيقات التطبيق ما كان موجود بباك
الوقت ولحسن حظنا ان احنا في هذا الزمن
اعتقد كان حصل في نقله نوعيه في استخدام
التطبيقات المنافسه محدوده
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
وعشان اقفل هذه المرحله ابغى الخصها اني
اسالك كم استثمرت في 2007 وكم طلعت لما
تخرجت 2010 استثمرت انا ما احب اذكر
الارقام بس اقدر اقول لك ان كنت مليونير
وانا عمري يمكن
26 سنه 26 سنه كم اكس جاب لك الاستثمار
جاب لي يمكن
على مستوى شخصي يمكن
فيعني 700% تقريبا نعم واذكر ليش انا اذكر
شنو شنو النقله اللي صارت فعلا اللي غيرت
من تفكيري انا اذكر في عام 2009 شهر
ثمانيه تم الاستحواذ على مكتوب دوت كوم من
قبل ياهو
ابعد من الرقعه الجغرافيه اللي احنا نشتغل
فيها
فاذكر تواصلت مع الاخوه في مكتوب حاولت
افهم تواصلت مع ارامكس وبحكم انه كانوا
مستثمرين كذلك فهد بنفسه وفهمت شنو العالم
اللي احنا مواعين له سبحان الله يا اخي
الانسان يعني عدو ما يجهل واحيانا انت
اللي تقيد نفسك فقط من خلال حلمك وتفكيرك
فوقتها قمت افكر بشكل اوسع وليش احنا
نشتغل فقط بالكويت او السعوديه شنو خطتنا
حق الخليج
الهام او
الاشعاع صراحه او الشراره اللي خلتني فعلا
افكر بشكل اوسع واوسع مدار كي وتفكيري
فاذا قلنا بنقفل هذا الشابتر
بالفعل استمريت انا مع اخوي محمد وكان
يدير انا استمريت بشكل غير تنفيذي فانا
موجود بس مو موجود
نهايه 2014 بس الاعلان عنا في 2015 كان
معلن رقم صح نعم
صفقه في العالم العربي بذاك الوقت بس خلال
كم كانت كانت 160
مليون دولار
او خلال الفتره هذه الله يحفظك
درست فبعد طلبات اتفقنا انه محمد هو بكمل
الاداره وانا مالي دخل انا موجود بشكل غير
تنفيذي
درست ماجستير
وكنت ابيع تخصص في الراس المال المغامر من
تركعته ما كان له اسم ابو عبد الرحمن وكان
في اخوه موجودين بالسعوديه فحتى التمويل
كان محدود بس كان فيه اذكر عنه
مثلا عفوا فارس الراشد أي فارس الراشد بس
ملابس كافه اذكر رشيد البلاح الله فكان في
مجموعه
عقال مع فارس رشيد انت في وملائز
وكان في ترى ما شاء الله حتى بذاك الوقت
يمكن تطبيقي او ثلاثه سعوديين ممتازين
ممتازين كان في موقع ارقام ما نذكرها عدل
عسير الله يذكره بالخير
بذاك الوقت ونموذج شلون الترفيه يكون عبر
المنصه الموجوده عندهم بالخير كذلك
فرحت درست فعلا وقدمت على جامعه واحده لان
ابي هالجامعه وابي اخذ ثقافه معينه والحمد
لله خلاص
ويجيت الكويت انا ويا احد الشركاء رحت
شركه سابق اللي كنت اشتغل فيها وقلت لهم
ابي اسس
هذا كان ب 2012
شلون ما لونش تقول قلت له ما انا محتاجين
احنا فلوس فيه طلبات
وفي بعض الشركات اون لاين اللي حاب اني
استثمر معهم
تشاركنا ورحنا من اسره
ميسوره يعني اسرى تجاريه ولا ولا محنا
اسره ميسوره الحمد لله رب العالمين
سواء كان خوالي والاعمامي فالوصول لرؤوس
الاموال ما هو من خلال العائله لا ابدا
ابدا ابدا
كان من خلال المستثمرين نشتغل معاهم
انا والدي يعني عكس ذلك تماما يعني مهما
حاول ما هي مكتوبه للتجاره
اهتمامه اكثر بالادب والتاريخ على العموم
اخذت منه اشياء ممكن نسولف
فرحنا للدوله عشان نسوي الصندوق
والدوله قالت ابد احنا نبيك تسوي هالشيء
يا عبد العزيز لكن مع الحكومه شلون
اسسنا بذاك الوقت
مؤسسه عامه مستقله معنيه برياده الاعمال
بدوله الكويت كان بالتزامن مع بقيه دول
الخليج في السعوديه كانت منشات على قيد
التاسيس وكان في مؤسسه محمد بن راشد في
دبي 2016 الحين
واربعه عشر
[موسيقى]
واتفقنا انا والشركه معايا بالفعل هذا
الشيء مناسب وممكن يختلف يعني يهدف عفوا
ابعاد اكبر واوسع من نطاق طلبات وجل نسوي
واسسنا صندوق الكويت صندوق الوطني لرعايه
وتنميه مشروعات صغيره انا وهذا اسف وبدر
قاطعتك هذا بنسولف عنه في المحور الثاني
بس انا ابغى اكمل الحين قصه الرياده او
الاعمال بالانتقال الفلاور حلو شلون صارت
قصه فلور وشلون دخلت السوق السعودي وايش
الفروقات اللي لاحظتها بين تجربه طلبات
وبين تجربه
ممتاز اعتقد على الصندوق الوطني ومنشات
ممكن ندش منها الزاويه اوكي خلينا نشوف
السعوديه بشكل عام شو اللي موجود وشو اللي
اختلف علينا قبل لا ندش سعود السوق
السعودي في فلاور
بني تحتيه
من ناحيه التطور الملحوظ اللي عملت فيه
سامه مع البنوك والمدفوعات الرقميه
اعتقد في جهد جبار عدن
بذاك الوقت البنيه التحتيه كذلك من جانب
اللوجي فصار فيه اليوم
مراكز تخزين ومراكز عمليات واسطول سيايير
لخدم كل انواع البزنسز ففي خدمات كثيره
موجوده
بنيه تحتيه للانترنت يعني انا اعتقد اللي
حصل
بغضون سنتين يمكن من الرؤيه
ما حصل في اي مكان اخر
شلون توصلت الفايبر كيبلز هذه لكل انحاء
المملكه وصارت بكلفه رمزيه يمكن ارخص من
السابق على تحديد
التحول الكبير في استهلاك الناس من
الهواتف الذكيه وشلون صارت جزء من حياتنا
يمكن التطبيق هو دارج اكثر من استخدام
الويب سايت نفسه
واعتقد انه
البنيه التحتيه كانت بشكل كبير افضل
وهذا الشيء انعكس على معدل التجاره
الالكترونيه فمن
اثنين اصبح اليوم ما طلعت النتائج الاخيره
بس اعتقد المملكه تجاوزت قرابه الاثنين
بالمئه
من 2022 او توقعاتنا هي تكون قرابه
الاثنين اي ما يعادل يمكن عشره اضعاف عشره
اضعاف بخمس سنوات ترى
مو سهل ما تحصل كم من المتوسط العالمي في
اوروبا
وامريكا يعتبر في يعني بنهايه التعش
فخلينا نقول 15 الى عشرين بالمئه بريطانيا
يمكن معدلها اعلى من بعد دول الغرب فوق
العشرين بالمئه يمكن مشوار قدامنا طويل
كذلك جدا جدا منطقه توها كل اللي صاير هذا
على على اثنين في الميه هذه وصلنا لعشرين
في المئه تصور ابو عبد الرحمن انه حجم
اقتصادنا في العالم العربي يقارب الثلاثه
فاصله خمسه ترليون دولار
منا يعني ما يتجاوز الستين مليار دولار
اقل ودون الاثنين بالمئه عدل وهذه الاثنين
حتى لو نبشت فيها شوي راح تلقى ان قطاع
السياحه والسفر هنا نمبر وان وهو من زمان
يعني
متميز بعدين يمكن يليها الاكل ليش بلشنا
نبكر احنا في السابق وعندك الملابس
والازياء والالكترونيات لكن باقي القطاعات
حتى لو في محاولات حتى لو بالورد فلان ورد
احنا موجودين ترى لا يزال عباره عن صحه
نعيشها بالعالم الرقمي لازلنا في كثير من
القطاعات
للحين ما اشتغلناها
اعتقد التطور الملحوظ اللي حصل في البنيه
التحتيه ساعد كثير بدايتنا الاهم من ذلك
هو اللي تفضلت فيه الرؤيه
الرؤيه ترى يعني
وش علاقه رؤيه السعوديه في الكويت ما لها
علاقه بس انا نتكلم عن السوق السعودي عدل
فاحنا لما نقول بلشنا بالبدايه
اشرب قهوه ترى قبل لا تبرك
نشفنا ريقك معلش
البدايه سلمت الله كنت مستثمر في شركه
اسمها
كانت اشتغلت تبيع ورد
اون لاين
انت بذاك الوقت سلمك الله الشركه
عقب عملي بالحكومه قالولي شوفي عبد العزيز
الوضع مو زين
وفي ملاحظات كثيره على اداء الشركه وانا
كنت مؤمن فعلا ان هناك قطاع كبير
وفعلا في فرصه كبيره لكن احنا محنا قادرين
نقدم افضل خدمه حق عملائنا
فاتفقنا كشركه ان بدال
ناس الشركه جديده
ونقول للشركاء القدامى راحت عليكم وخصوصا
انا مستثمر حالي من حال البقيه يعني بذاك
الوقت قلنا
احنا بنضحي في النموذج العمل لو تاسس شركه
اليوم وعبد الرحمن يستثمر معاي غالبا ما
راح تحط ريال
واذا تكلفه راس المال للريال راح تاخذ
نفترض والله عشرين بالمئه من الشركه صح
لان المبادر والفريق راح ياخذون 80%
ويكملون ويطولون احنا قلنا بهذا كله
احنا نعتقد انه في فرصه واحده بهذا القطع
حجم قطاع الزهور في الخليج كان واحد فاصله
خمسه مليار دولار والهدايا اوسع من ذلك بس
الورود بالنسبه لنا كانت يمكن الاكثر فرصه
او الاكثر نعتقد الاكثر نجاحا يعني
عبد العزيز يمسك الشركه
وفعلا مسكنه الشركه اول شيء قررنا اننا
الشركه جديده في الكامل بناخذ اللي نقدر
عليه او اللي ممكن يفيدنا وكانت كان الاهم
اعتقد هو فريق العمل اللي موجود
ونبني عليه ونسوي علامه جديده ونحط نموذج
عمل فعلا يحاكي الواقع الملموس ويقدم ميزه
تنافسيه عاليه
واعتقد هذا اللي عملناه في البدايه ركزنا
على اشياء بسيطه لانه الاساس هو
مين يقدر يتخيل انه ممكن تسوي شركه بس
تبيع ورد
العقل والله ابو عبد الرحمن اللي يخليك
وانا من مدرسه اللي يركز
في بحر واحد بعدين هذا السوق حجمه واحد
فاصله خمسه مليار
في الاف المحلات التقليديه اللي موجوده ما
حد متصدر المشهد على مستوى الخليج محد
متصدر المشهد على الانترنت
والخدمه اللي موجوده حتى لو كانت في
الانترنت او المحلات التقليديه الخدمه
اللي موجوده متواضعه وما شاء الله فيه
كثير منهم تصاميم حلوه فقلنا لا مو موضوع
تصاميم فقط العمل يبي تشكيله واسعه يبي كل
مقدور عليها
يبي
التطبيق او الاستخدام عبر الانترنت يكون
فيه سهوله وتجربه العميل تكون سهله للغايه
يبي سرعه بالتوصيل
ربعنا ومجتمعنا دائما اخرنا يعني
بالمناسبات كثير منهم ما يطلبون ما
يتاخرون
والنبي خدمه عملاء مميزه فقلنا طيب هذه
الاشياء الاساسيه لازم احنا نوفرها
بمهنيه عاليه وبتجربه مميزه وبلشنا في
الكويت نفس ما تفضلت لغينا الشركه الاوليه
وبلشنا اسم
دمجناهم مع بعض صارت
وكان دائما من اليوم الاول
العنوان او السلوقن اللي نستعمله هو ورود
وهدايا اون لاين من اول يوم
في الهدايا جزء من الرؤيه من البدايه نعم
نعم
ولذلك كان دائما يعني
نحرص ان نقدم الخدمات الاساسيه
ويكون في رؤيه واضحه حق فريق عملنا نشتغل
معه والرؤيه هذه كانت من اليوم الاول
غير السوق وحجمه دائما نربطه مع عاداتنا
وتقاليدنا وقيمنا وثقافتنا كمجتمع في
الكويت وبالدول الخليج يعني فعشان كده كان
دائما حملاتنا
وداخل الفريق دائما نقول من لا يشكر الناس
لا يشكر الله
وثقافتنا كعرب يمكن الكرم والجود
تستر السخائيل فكل عيب يغطيه كما قيل
السخاء كانت دائما موجوده من من بداياتنا
بلشنا في الكويت العام 2017 متى قررت سوق
السعودي في 2018 بس هالمره قلنا يعني لا
يلدغ المؤمنه من مرتين صح فما راح نروح
بنموذج فرانشايز لا لا احنا بنشتغل
بانفسنا لكن
كنت اقول ما راح ادق مسمار
الا لين القى شريك مثلي واحسن مني
وبالفعل اعتقد كنا كنت ادور عن طريق
الاصدقاء
والاهله او الناس اللي نتعامل معهم الين
الله وفجني لله الحمد وان شاء الله يكون
ربي يوفقها واكون عند حسن ظنه باخوي محمد
العريفي بو سعود ابو سعود
شهادتي في مجروحه وما ابي اتكلم عنه صراحه
كثير لكن
اعتقد كنت اشوف ان ابي شخص يكملني بس
اعتقد باشياء كثيره هو صراحه تفوق علي
فيها وهذا الفريق مو بس محمد بس ليش اخترت
محمد ما رحت
جربته سابقا وكان ماشي معك تمام وريحك
واعتقد احسن مثال والواحد يعني صراحه
يفتخر
اتوا من بعدنا ناس في قطاع المطاعم وسوي
التطبيقات تفوقت على طابات طلبات عده مرات
وبالنهايه تم الاستحواذ علينا كلنا من قبل
نفس الطرف
الغوا تطبيق طلبات بالسعوديه والان
التطبيق الاخر هو اللي متميز صح فبالعكس
انا اعتقد اذا كان في عبر اخذناها ومواعظ
نفسك توسع نفسك ولازم تلقى شخص نفسك واحسن
منك يفهم السوق المحلي عنده علاقاته عنده
ثقافته وهذا الشيء ينطبق مو بس على ابو
سعود هذا الشيء ينطبق على كل فريق العمل
فعشان كذا يمكن بس ما سويتوها في بقيه
الدول
سوينا اللي تفضلت فيه سويناه يعني عندك
شريك في الامارات
عباره شريك او او مصطلح شريك ترى شلناه
انا اليوم ما استخدم مفرد مؤسس ورئيس
الشركه لا لان صراحه اللي اسسوا الشركه
كثار
وجزء من قيامنا
اللي تنصب بشكل مباشر من رؤيتنا اذا
رؤيتنا هنا ان احنا نكون الوجهه المفضله
للورود والهدايا في الشرق الاوسط
فتاكد ان احنا عندنا قيم ومبادئ واضحه
كثير وجزء من ثقافتنا تنغرس كل يوم احدها
انه في فرص متكافئه وما يصير يا اخي
الافكار تقيم على اساس من اللي قالها صح
هي على كفاءتها وقدرتها بس اقصد من حيث
المبدا هل طبقت نفس الفكره في كل سوق
تدخله اللي كان فيه احد من ابن السوق هو
اللي
تقدير القطاع في كل يدير البلد فاحنا
كهيكل عندنا
التسويق التكنولوجيا العمليات وبعدين
عندنا فريق النمو اللي هو في كل بلد عندنا
مدير الدوله اوكي
وبلشنا 2018 دخلت السوق السعودي ما دخلنا
2018 فكرنا 2019 دخلنا السوق السعودي
البيئه اللي بذاك الوقت موجوده يمكن نرد
لها فاحنا قلنا بنيه تحتيه ممتازه
صار في
ادوات تمويل كثيره
دخل معكم احد منهم اي نعم لاحقا بس ابي
اقول لك عشان تخيل المشهد شنو البيئه اللي
موجوده صح فصار في عندك انت مجتمع رواد
مو صار في
منشات
اليوم
وبودكاست صغرت هذا مجتمع كامل صح ما كان
موجود تمام صار في عندك
صناديق الراس مال جريء نفس ما ذكرناه وانا
هني يمكن نبي نوقف دقيقه عن شنو اثر
صناديق راس المال اللي ممكن يعني يلقي
بظفافه علينا صح فانت اليوم حاله وشعب
ورواد اعمام ما شاء الله كثيرين بس ترى
المال
ممكن يغير حياتك ممكن يغير تفكيرك ممكن
يغير احلامك وما بالك اذا كان هذا المال
عند ناس اذكى بعد وشطار وعارفين شنو ابعاد
صناعه الراس المال الجريء احلامك التغير
فعلا فعلا احلامك تغير وصار بوسعك انه
تقدر انت تستقطب احسن مهارات مو قلنا
بالسابق ما نقدر الا البنوك وشركات
الاتصالات
اليوم لا اليوم صار بوسعك انت تستقطب احسن
مواهب وعندك القدره والكفاءه الماليه اللي
تقدر تساعدك بهذا الشيء ومو بس الكفاءات
المحليه وان شاء الله تطوروا الشباب
والبنات في السعوديه مو بس كفاءات محليه
حتى الكفاءات العالميه اعيش يعني تجربه
الدخول للسوق السعودي كاجراءات هل كان في
نافذه وحده لانهاء كل اجراءاتكم ايش
الجهات اللي كانت ميسره في التجربه ايش
الجهات اللي تعبتكم في الدخول السوق
السعودي بصفتكم مستثمر خليجي ما بدات انت
من هنا مفهوم
الاجراءات سهله بكثير وتم تسهيلها يعني
على ابعد مدد انا اذكر كنا ننجز معاملاتنا
واحنا واقفين في بعض الجهات الحكوميه
طبعا التحول الرقمي الكبير اللي حصل في
الدوله اكيد ساعدنا كثير
ناهيك عن يعني اذا كان دور الدوله في
السابق هو دور رقابي وتنظيمي الان ابعد من
ذلك صار صار دور الدوله ان شلون ننهض في
هذه
الشريحه من الاقتصاد نقدر نعاونها صح
فاذا كان يعني سهوله التواصل مع المسؤولين
في الدوله وعرض افكارك واي تطور اي
تحديثات انت تبي تحاكي فيه يمكن كان
التواصل مع
المسؤولين واصحاب المعالي الوزراء
من التواصل مع التليفون البقاله اللي جنب
بيتكم تمام
فهذه اكيد ساعدتنا الانجاز
الوكالات والمعاملات الحكوميه كلها تنجز
او اون لاين واعتقد اعتقد انا اليوم اقدر
اقول
انه يمكن هي الاسهل في الخليج كل الخليج
اليوم اسهل من كل الخليج كتعاملات حكوميه
واذا كان في تحديات انا متاكد ان واعيين
لها وقاعد يشتغلون يطورونها بشكل دوري
[موسيقى]
2019 الى اليوم وش اللي اللي صار الفلاور
في السعوديه وفي لورد عموما
اوكي
ثقافيه ثقافيا السعوديه شهدت تغير كبير
وانا ما اعتقد ان هذا التغير
وبالناس بقدر ما هو تغير بالدوله يعني
الناس متعلمه من قبل لا تكون الرؤيه
موجوده والناس ما شاء الله كثقافه لو تقول
لي سطر لي خمس كتاب ادب روايه شعر بسطر لك
خمسه من خمسين سنه صح والفن والرياضه
والناس الردي جاهزه للرؤيه صح وهذا يمكن
يساعد في التحول سوى ثقافيا حصل فيه تغير
انا اذكر اول ما اشتغلنا في السعوديه كنا
نخاف في بعض المناسبات اننا نعرض منتجاتنا
لانه يمكن المجتمع ما يتقبلها فتذكر
في فبراير ايه في المستودع في 2020
2019 2019
لا لا لا تورطنا بالفعل بالفعل الفبراير
صحيح صحيح ففي ثقافيين تغيرات كثيره حصلت
وانا اعتقد الشعب كان مستعد لهذه الدوله
اللي مرت في تغير ثقافي اكثر من
الشعب فهذه البيئه اللي احنا فيها الان
فلاورد بلشت وكان يهمنا حيل غرس ثقافه
فلور وربطها بالمجتمع اللي نشتغل فيه فلما
اليوم تقول
الارتباط الثقافي الديني المجتمع اللي
احنا ذكرناها قبل شوي ابعد من ذلك شلون
نشتغل احنا مع السوق المحلي فسواء كنا
نشتري الورود من بعض المزارع المحليه او
نتعامل مع مصممين يسمون مباقات خاصه فيهم
محليين نتعامل مع كثير من العلامات
التجاريه لانه اصبح فلاود مو بس يبيع ورد
مثل بدايته اصبح فلورت هي منصه لبيع كل
انواع الهدايا لتطري على بالك وهذه كلها
بالتعاون معه منتجات محليه او علامات
تجاريه محليه
تعاونا مع
الجانب الخيري والرعايه الاجتماعيه عندنا
متوسط كل اسبوع في عمل خيري او نشاط
اجتماعي يقوم فيه خلال السنتين اللي فاتوا
هذا على مستوى السعوديه هذا على مستوى
بالسعوديه يمكن نصيب الاسد
[موسيقى]
العمل الخيري التقليدي يمكن يكون محصور في
افطار صائم وانك تبني مسيد ولا بتسوي لكن
هو اوسع من ذلك صح فاليوم في كثير من
الناس اللي ما عندهم القدره انهم يدرسون
احنا نساعدهم في كثير من الايتام او يعني
يعني بالتعاون مثلا مع مركز الملك سلمان
الايتام او بالتعاون مع جمعيه خيريه
الخاصه بكذا اخرها الله يحفظك عبد الرحمن
هو اطلاق فلور الشهر الماضي يعني الشهر
الماضي ترى يعني اقصد نهايه السنه الماضيه
اطلاق فلور لغه برايل فاليوم الله يقومهم
بالسلامه المكفوفين
باستطاعتهم انهم يستقبلون هدايا ومن خلال
الكرت اللي يوصل لك
وباللمس
يقدرون يقرون الرساله كل عام وانت بخير يا
فلانه والحمد لله على السلامه يا فلانه
فهذه الاعمال ما توقف عندنا وهذا اللي
خلانا نكون اقرب للمجتمع تعاونا مع
الرياضه
يمكن مع تحديد النادي الهلال وش اللي
سويناه او الرياضه بشكل اوسع مع اللجنه
الاولمبيه في السعوديه
بشتى انواع الرياضه اللي نشتغل معاهم هذي
كلها مسؤوليه مجتمعيه ونعتقد هذا فعلا
واجبنا ونقوم فيه واحيانا كثيره ترى ما
نعلن عنه ولا يعني جاهر في هذه العماله
نقوم فيها واليوم كم موظف في فلورت اليوم
الحمد لله
وصلنا الى تقريبا 1200 بطل وبطله يشتغلون
معنا
تقريبا نصهم 500 الى 600
شاب وشاب يشتغلون معانا ومنها هؤلاء يمكن
في قرابه
200 سعودي وسعوديه اي نعم تسعة هذه
الوظائف اللي خلقناها بشكل مباشر فيها
كثير في يعني
وظائف الاخرى اللي خلقناها بشكل غير مباشر
اكثر بكثير وكم السوق السعودي من من
مبيعات وهذا اللي تغير بالفعل من قبل
الرؤيه وبعد الرؤيه قبل الرؤيه كان السوق
السعودي ما يشكل شيء من المبيعاتنا قبل
كذلك ومن مبيعات كثير من الشركات
اليوم اذا حجم السعوديه من اقتصاد الخليج
50% سوقنا اليوم 50% السعوديه
من السوق السعودي
واعتقد من التغيرات الكبيره كمان بالبيئه
اللي حصلت
موضوع مره ثانيه راس المال الجريء مو سهل
مو سهل بو عبد الرحمن ان الدوله تقول تعال
انا بسخر هل كثر مليون او مليار ريال ابي
استثمرها
لان عبر
هذه احصائيه صراحه ما كنا واعين لها لكن
الان تاكدت عبر ثمانيه عبر احد البرامج
معكم
كان الله يذكره بالخير عبد العزيز العمران
50 مليون ريال من الدوله صح
وهذه الخمسين مليون عوائدها للدوله اكثر
من مليار ريال
فلو تفكر فيها شنو العوائد اللي ممكن
تحققها الدوله هو مو من الاستثمار فقط وهم
من الضرائب من الرسوم من الزكاه تمنعها
مضاعفات من صناديق السعوديه دخلوا معاكم
والله احنا محظوظين في
امباكت بسمه سنيدي وعبد العزيز العمران
ومحظوظين صراحه في اس تي في يعني عبد
الرحمن ترى بزوني واحمد النعيمي
هؤلاء الناس وهذا يدور المستثمر الجريء صح
هؤلاء الناس ترى مو دورهم انه يعاييك ولا
يكاسر فيك انه تقييمك هالكثر ولا لا زايد
ولا قاصر عشره بالمئه
شلون يخليك تحلم اكبر وهو كون ان عنده
ادوات التمويل هذه اللي موجوده
قادر انه يوجه بشكل مباشر كيف تفكر وشنو
مدى احلامك صح فيمكن احنا بلشنا وكان
الحلم انه نصير مئه مليون دولار شركه
هذا فعلا ترى واقع وهذا كان حلو
ومحمد وبقيه
الشركه الشباب يعني الفريق اللي موجوده
معنا نصبح ميه مليون دولار
وانا متاكد انه بشكل مباشر
ساهموا بشكل كبير
توسيع احلامنا
هذا الحلم صار اكبر واكبر واكبر واستثمروا
معانا على عده مراحل مو مرحله واحده فقط
واحنا صراحه يعني محظوظين في
هؤلاء النماذج يعني وفي غيرهم ان شاء الله
بعد احسن بس اعتقد كنا محظوظين فعلا باللي
عملناه وعشان ابو بدر ما تصير الصوره
فلاورديه خلينا نتكلم على ايش التحديات
اللي لا تزال موجوده اليوم في بيئه
الاستثمار في السعوديه وايش اللي ينقص هذا
البيئه حتى تكون عشره اضعاف ولمئه ضعف
قدراتها الحاليه وش التحديات اللي واجهتكم
فخلنا نوقف عند نهايه عام 22 او بدايه عام
23 حلو بالضبط اللي احنا فيه الان
خلينا نبلش بالرؤيه هذا البرنامج اصلا عن
الرؤيه انا اعتقد ان الرؤيه بالنسبه لي
على الاقل صارت مثل الموناليزا شلون يا
اخي من كل جانب تشوفها هي تطالعك صح
وبالفعل الرؤيه من كل زاويه تشوفها تلقي
بظفافها عليك ولها اثر بشكل مباشر باللي
احنا
تتكلم عن الراس المال الجريء
بدون راس المال الجريء هذا ما كنا ممكن
نحقق ربع الاحلام اللي احنا الحمد لله
وصلنا له بدون البنيه التحتيه للدوله ما
كان ممكن يتحول معدل التجاره الالكترونيه
او يتضاعف بعشر مرات خلال الخمس ست سنوات
الماضيه صح بدون الرؤيه المدفوعات الرقميه
يا اخي شلون تشتغل التحول الرقمي اللي حصل
في الدوله ودفع بشكل مباشر الشاب ولا
الشاب او المواطن السعودي او كذلك الاجنبي
انه يستفيد من خدمات الدوله عبر الانترنت
الرؤيه اوسع وتسع الجميع الرؤيه ما اصبحت
فقط للسعوديين
هذه بلدك تعال اشتغل طالما انك تشتغل
عندنا في السعوديه هذه الرؤيه تاكد ان
اليوم اصبحت هي
قبله كل الرياضيين الاعمال
في السعوديه مكه المكرمه هي قبله المسلمين
انا اقول السعوديه هي اليوم قبلت كل رواد
الاعمال في العالم
تحولتوا الى شركه سعوديه في وبالفعل نحن
الان يعني ممكن هذا يكون المدخل لسؤالك
انه شنو ممكن نطور
بسبب بعض القوانين
واحنا حاليا في منطقه حره خارج السعوديه
الشركه الام او بلد المنشا هناك
واخذنا هذا المنشا او هذا المقر لنا لعده
اسباب اهمها
ان قانون الشركات قانون الشركات
بالنموذج الجديد في حصل عليه التغييرات
الايجابيه الحقيقه بس لا زال في فرص
للتطور اتفاقيات المساهمين لا زالت غير
محترف فيها في السعوديه
نظام الشركات اتفاقيات المساهمين النموذج
لعقد التاسيس
يحكم العلاقه ما بين الشركاء وكذلك
الاداره هذه العلاقه في له نموذج شبه شابت
في ثابت في عقود التاسيس في الدوله ممكن
تتطور
في اشياء
لشركات الخارج اوكي فهذه نقطه تحتاج لسه
تحسين حتى بنظام الجديد للاستفاده اوكي
اتفاقيات المساهمين في اشياء كثيره خارج
عقود التاسيس احنا كشرك انا بنتفق على
واحد اثنين ثلاثه
اليوم معنا في حال الله لا يقول الشركه
فلست
القانون الفلاس الاسعار محتاج تحديث
فالشركه يتفقون خارج عقد التاسيس لان
الدوله ما تضمن هذه الحقوق بشكل واضح او
او مو ما تضمن الحقوق هي تضمن الحقوق لكن
بالتساوي ما بين كل الشراكه انت لا تبي
تميز بين شريك اكس الف باء
الشروط او التعاقدات ممكن يكون تطويرها
للسوق ولا لا للفعل
فلان الان الله يحفظك احنا في صدد اعاده
الهيكله وان يكون في شركه سعوديه هي اللي
تكون الشركه الام والقابضه انه مقر عملنا
ونشاطنا اكيد من زمان في السعوديه
بس هيكليا لازم تكون الشركه في السعوديه
عشان تطرح نعم
طرح المزدوج في امريكانا ادرجت في سوق
وما كان فيها طرح عام
فهو ادراك كان في طرحان
الاخوه مثل ما ذكرت لك انا في الجهات
الرقابيه تحديدا هيئه السوق
اعطونا المراحل اللي راح يمر فيها
وشلون ممكن ادراج الشركات
مسجله في السعوديه
من شروط الادراج حسب
الفلور
تتهيا له نعم انها تكون شركه سعوديه ليش
لان شرط الادراج المزدوج يمكن ما ينطبق
علينا اوكي
اعاده الهيكله نفس ما تفضلت اليوم يعني
نسبه عاليه ما ابي اقول للكل من الشباب
والشركات في السعوديه كلنا
والصناديق
معظمهم مسجلين برا ليش للاسباب اللي
ذكرناها
فهذا هذول يدرجون
هي معاناه بس فرص للتطوير فلما اليوم انت
صحيح مسجل بره وتعامل معامله الاجنبيه من
خلال ميزه وزاره الاستثمار
يفترض ان هذه الصناديق
بشكل غير مباشر هي ملك الدوله اليوم معنا
شريك نفيف لاورد اكبر مستثمر هي الدوله صح
عبر الصناديق اللي ذكرناها يعني لانه
صندوق راس مال خاص ما هو ما هو صندوق دوله
معظمه من اس بي سي واس في سي ممكن الدوله
اوكي
كذلك معظمه من اس تي سي واس تي سي 70%
مدرجه للدوله صح بس في اموال خاصه في احنا
نقوله انها تلك الاموال حتى لو هي مسجله
بره بالواقع هي اموال سعوديه صح اوكي
وسواء كانت مواطنين او دوله عدل فاعتقد في
فرصه كبيره
وش المشكله تسجل امام وزاره الاستثمار
انها مو الاجنبيه لان هذه الشركه الام
موجوده برا صح
وليست هنا المشكلات اتوقعكم انها تطبق
عليها ضرائب تطبق عليها ضرائب في ثلاث
انواع ايوه في ضريبه اللي هي
الارباح الراسماليه
وامام الاخوه في ذات كذلك الاخوه في وزاره
الماليه برنامج
التطوير في كثير من
العناصر الحقيقه اللي قاعد يعاونوا لنا
فيها وقعد نحاول نجد لها اليوم
جاهزين للطرح احنا اليوم مو جاهزين في
عندنا اهداف تجاريه اعمال فيها
وباذن الله راح مستهدفين الطرح والله يعني
اعتقد خلال السنتين القادمي
فلازم نستعد بس رحله يعني خل الجزء اللي
داخل عندكم هذا تتولونه بس انا ابغى اقيس
على تجربه شركه قررت اليوم انها تدخل
للسوق رحلتكم لهذا لهذا الهدف اللي مرتبطه
بالجهات الحكوميه هيئه السوق الماليه
تحديدا كم هذه
في تقديركم انت تتكلم على سنه ونص سنه سنه
ونص اوكي سنه سنه ونص من استيفائك للشروط
ومن ثم التقديم ومراجعتها واطول فقره في
هذه السلسله وش هي
اعاده الهيكلة اعاده الهيكله الجانب
القانوني اعاده هيكله راح تاخذ وقت كثير
لان لا زالت القوانين مثل ما ذكرنا في فرص
لتطويرها واكبر تحدي فيها هو راس المال
هذا ايوه ضريبه راس المال اوكي ضريبه
الارباح الراسماليه لانه هيئه الزكاه
الدخل حتاخذ عليكم فرق ايوه
طبعا الاخوه المتفهمين وبالعكس جدا
متعاونين واعتقد راح يوصلون حق حل اهم شيء
لما تعالج تحديات اللي تواجه رواد الاعمال
او صناديق راس مال الجري
اهم شيء انك تعرف بالضبط شو المشكله
وانها تمس شريحه كبيره من
المواطنين او المستثمرين اللي موجودين
ونتعالجها بشكل سريع لان اليوم
ما اعتقد في شركه تشتغل في عده دول ومعها
مستثمرين سعوديين او اجانب راح يقدرون
يدشون السوق بدون لا تنطبق عليهم هذه
الضرائب وما دام قاعد نطرب وبدر موضوع
جنسيه الشركات الى اليوم ما اعرف انا وش
العنصر اللي بلال عليه تعطى الشركه هذا
الجنسيه هل هو بحسب مكان التاسيس ولا بحسب
اكبر الاسواق ولا الهيد كوارتر او المقر
الرئيسي وشلون نطلق على هذه الشركه
السعوديه ولا اماراتيه ولا كويتيه
في عده تصانيف او معايير اللي تفضلت فيها
كلها تنطبق عليها بس غالبا ما الشركه الام
وين تكون وين مؤسسه الشركه الام قانونيا
تنطبق عليها
[موسيقى]
الجنسيه
صح الحمد لله تم دعوتنا له
وعرفنا على هالبرنامج
في ثلاثه او اربع اشياء احنا نطمح لها
للامانه اللقاء التعريفي راح يكون قريب ان
شاء الله فما اعلن بالكامل عن شنو بس احنا
انت طلع لي اربع اشياء الاول هو الجانب
التعاملات الحكوميه تطوير القوانين والنظم
وما هي ما هي خاصه في فلاور لازم تكون
للجميع
فاول شيء تطوير النظم واللوائح والقوانين
اللي خاصه في السعوديه
رقم الاثنين الدوله لا زالت اكبر مستهلك
فاعطاء فرصه
لرواد الاعمال انهم ينافسون في المشتريات
اكيد في مناقصات وفي اوامر مباشره
واعتماداته انه يعطون فرصه كلا في مجاله
انه يشتغل ويقدم على هذا الشيء ثلاثه
المساعدات خارج
الدوله وهذا لمسناه بشكل مباشر حتى في قبل
البرنامج يعني الحمد لله احنا شهر 9
الماضي اعلنا ان تمنا نحن ترخيص كاس
العالم اول مره تاريخ كاس العالم يمنحون
ترخيص للورود فالحمد لله تم احنا هذا
الترخيص
وبالتعاون مع الاخوه في وزاره الاتصالات
يعني عونونا باشياء كثيره يعني قمنا فيها
فهذا التعاون خارج المملكه
له ابعاد كثيره وممكن نستفيد منه
الجزء الرابع هو مرتبط في
الادراج في السعوديه واذا احنا فعلا عندنا
قاعد نسعى ونبي ندرس في السعوديه شنو
العوامل اللي ممكن تساعدك انك تدرج اكثر
فهذه اعتقد ابرز ملامحه ولو تلتفت اليوم
الخلف ابو بدر في
2019 نتكلم على ثلاثه اربع سنوات صارت في
السعوديه ابغاك تذكر لي اكثر جهازين
حكوميه كان لوجودها اثر واضح على نجاحكم
وابغاك تذكر لي اكثر الجهتين تعتقد انه في
مساحه لتطوير عملهم حتى يمكن رواد الاعمال
بشكل اكثر من زاويه تجربه فلور
وابدا بالثاني قبل الاولى عشان ما تزحلق
اعتقد ان ان جانب القوانين
اوكي خل ناخذها بشكل اوسع لازم يصير فيه
توائم اكثر
بين الجهات الحكوميه تجاه تحقيق الرؤيه
يعني اليوم الرؤيه تلقي باهدافها على جميع
جهات على جميع جهات والمفروض هذه الاهداف
كلها تصب فيه الاهداف العامه مالته الرؤيه
الواقع عنا في بعض الجهات اهدافها تتضارب
مع الاخت مثل اليوم وزاره الاستثمار تشجع
المستثمر وتبي تعطيه بعض التسهيلات لكن
الاخوه في ذاتك يعني ما شاء الله عليهم
منشار صاعد نازل ناكل عدل وهذا واجبهم
بصراحه ولازم يقومون فيه واعتقد انه يعني
في عده حلقات تكلمت عن النظام الضريبي
ويمكن من الافضل اللي تم
تطبيقه يعني على مستوى العالم الثاني
الافضل بالعالم كان
لازم يتناغمون
يعني شويه تناغمون يعني انت تقول هذا واجب
واجب زاد كانها تزيد الامتثال حلو التحصيل
حلو فروحي القانون
هني اللي لازم احنا ننظر له اذا كان في
اعاده هيكله في حاله
او غيرها اليوم الشركه موجودين والشركه
الام في فريزون منطقه حره برا السعوديه هم
نفس الشركه بتملكون بالسعوديه وما في اي
تغيير بالملكيه ولا في بيع ولا في كذا ليش
تنطبق عليهم الضريبه اذا كان هو فقط تعامل
اجراء
فاعتقد ممكن ننظر الى ابعد من القانون
نفسه وهو النظر اللي يروح القانون هذه صح
فهذا مثلا ممكن
تناغم اكثر بين اهداف وزاره الاستثمار في
الجذب للاستثمارات الاجنبيه او الشركات
الاجنبيه ممكن يعني
يتعارض اليوم مع اللي قاعد يطبق من الفعل
بالفعل مثال اخر الضريبه كذلك
اليوم
كثير من الجهات في السعوديه
رؤوس اموالها ترى ما يخلونها في السعوديه
المستثمرين السعوديين او كويتيين الدوله
او غير الدوله تمام لكن الفلوس برا
السعوديه
فاليوم لما تشوف عجله المال السيوله ترى
كثير منها تروح للسعوديه عشان دفع رواتب
او مصاريف لكن رؤوس الاموال ليش عليها
ضرايب عليها ضريبه ايش فيقول لك انا ضريبه
ما اعرف اسمها صراحه بالعربي بس اليوم
مقابل كل مصروف كشركه
تصرفه خارج السعوديه وهذا وهذه الضريبه
كمان على السعوديين ترى مو بس الاستقطاع
5% هذه 5 الى 15 حسب نوع المصروف حسب اي
ريال يطلع برا السعوديه صح اي ريال يطلع
برا السعودي
من خمسه الى خمسه على حسب النشاط او
المصروف نفسه
هذه خلت كل
الايرادات تروح لحسابات برا على طول مو
قصدي الايرادات رؤوس الاموال
فاليوم انت لما تزيد راس مال في جوله
استثماريه اكس مليون دولار
صحابات بره والسبب انه
اتفاده هذه ويتحول بمقدار الرواتب ويتحول
مقدار
فهذه امثله بسيطه على القوانين شلون ممكن
تطوير واللي كلها تخص جهاز هيئه زكاه
الضريبه وتدخل وبالتعاون مع وزاره
الاستثمار فهذا اول جهاز يعني تعتقد انه
في تطوير اكثر لمنظومه
جهاز لسه قاعد يعني يعيق انطلاقاتكم او
ممكن يكون فيه تطوير اكثر له ما هو خاص في
السعوديه للامانه بس اذا نظرنا حق منظومه
الخليج
احنا اليوم بنشتغل فيه كثير من الدول صح
في السعوديه تمثل السوق الاكبر لنا لكن
نشتغل في تسع دول اوكي منها التسع ست دول
الخليج كل دوله لها نظام شركات لحالها
قانون شركات فتح الحسابات طريقه مختلفه
البضاعه
والجمارك يعني وحدوها لكن لازال في بعض
يعني المتطلبات اللي تختلف من دوله الى
اخرى فاعتقد
توحيد بقدر المستطاع النظام والقوانين ما
بين دول الخليج اللي خاصه في وزاره
التجاره الجمارك نقل البضائع وحريه وسهوله
انتقال البضائع هذه ما بين دول الخليج
اعتقد راح تخدمنا كلنا صراحه وخصوصا حق
الشركات السعوديه اللي تشتغل برا السعوديه
فهل منظومتين اعتقد راح يخدمون يخدمون
شريحه الرواد الاعمال هذه بشكل مباشر مع
الجانب الثاني مين اكثر جهتين ساهموا في
القفزه اللي حققتوها
[موسيقى]
لا شك وزاره الاتصالات وتقنيه المعلومات
يمكن على راسه والسبب هو مو ضروري الفلاور
لما انت تقدر توفر الانترنت بهذه السرعه
لشريحه كبيره من المجتمع
وبالتكلفه هذه الرمزيه
تاكد ترى ان انه راح يزيد بشكل مباشر من
معدل التجاره الالكترونيه اعتقد
المدفوعات الرقميه اللي هو يمكن جزء منها
مرتبط في المركزي او وزاره الماليه كذلك
فاعتقد هذه الجهات اللي ساعدت في نهضه
البنيه التحتيه ساهمت بشكل مباشر في
زياده معدل التجاره الالكترونيه اللي حصل
في كوفيد يمكن مو وزاره صراحه وجهه حكوميه
حكومه واكملها الحكومه باكملها صح حكومه
باكملها تحولت اون لاين
وشجعت الناس انه لا تطلع خلك في بيتك
وحافظ على سلامتك واستخدمها للتطبيقات هذه
المختلفه اللي موجوده
فاعتقد احنا احنا محظوظين انه قاعد عاصر
التحول اللي حصل
نحن جزء من الحمد لله لو بسوي زوماوت
او قبل ما نسوي اقفل الملف فلاوورد باهم
الارقام عشان ما نظلم هالتجربه اليوم انتم
كم مدينه شغالين كم المبيعات كامل توصلون
لو نلخص اهم ارقام فلورد اليوم باقفال 22
حلو فلله الحمد احنا اليوم صار عندنا 1200
تقريبا بطل وبطله عندنا اكثر من 46 جنسيه
يشتغلون معانا نشتغل في تسع دول الخليج
زائد مصر والاردن وبريطانيا
عندنا اكثر من 22 مركز عمليات
يوفر نفس الخدمه
اللي هو التوصيل السريع والشريحه الكبيره
هذه الى اكثر من 37 مدينه لله الحمد
مبيعاتنا تعذرني بس اللي اقدر اقول لك
اياه
ان احنا
يمكن من اكثر خمس شركات
مبيعات اونلاين في العالم العربي في
العالم العربي نعم له الحمد كيف عرفت اذا
ما يقولون زيكم
يعني خلينا نقول السوق صغير واحنا عيال
قريه وكلنا نعرف
اعتقد ما شاء الله عليك انت مطلع وعارف
يعني كمان
في الحمد لله اعتقد كان عام 22
عام تحول كبير حصل عندنا الاعوام السابقه
لذلك كنا
كاداره ونموذج تفكير ثقافتنا كانت اكثر
على التوسع الجغرافي
فالعمليات
والنمو كان غالب على تفكيرنا
طبعا هذا النمو الحمد لله حققنا اشياء
كثيره ويمكن النمو بالسنتين ثلاث سنوات
الماضيه تجاوز الخمسين ضعف لله الحمد
لكن هذا النمو يبي له ترتيب بيتك ولازم
عواميدك تكون جاهزه
فنعتقد انه في السابق اهملنا جانب
البيانات
وتطوير
هيكلنا التنظيمي فكانت عام كان عام 2022
عام التركيز اكثر داخل البيت ولله الحمد
كنا يعني لازلنا حققنا انه واسع لله الحمد
في عام 2022 في كل الدول نشتغل فيها
بس ركزنا اكثر عليه تغيير ثقافتنا ونموذج
تفكيرنا من
المتطرف للنمو الى
خطوات واضحه بناء على البيانات فصارت
نموذج طريقه تفكيرنا مبنيه على اسس علميه
اكثر من في السابق ولذلك يمكن تشوف فريق
التكنولوجيا او
المنتج البرادكت من ناحيه
تجربه العميل فريق البيانات فريق
المنتجات شلون يتم ترتيبها يمكن تضاعف
بعشر اضعاف خلال السنه الماضيه
فهذا التحول حصل
غير نمونه الطبيعي في اسواقنا كذلك اتجهنا
لعمليات الاستحواذ والدمج ولله الحمد
استحوذنا حديثا تم الاعلان عنه الشهر
الماضي على شركه عطور عطور عربيه ونعتقد
هذا السوق واعد حجمه في الخليج قرابه
الاربعه مليار دولار وما شاء الله في ناس
متميزين جدا فبدالنا احنا نعيد اختراع
العجله
نشتغل لحالنا احنا مؤمنين تماما انه ايد
واحده ما تصفق تعاون مع فريق متمرس متمكن
اشطر منك في هذا المجال
ونحاول نسوي نفس الصناديق راس مال يسوونه
وانه نحاولوا نوسع احلامهم مع بعض فنعتقد
ان هذه الشركه شركه مبخر
لها تواجد بسيط عندنا بالمنطقه انك تشغلهم
معاك في السبع وثلاثين مدينه وتوفر نفس
الخدمه اللي قادر توفرها لعملائك راح
يخدمها بشكل كبير كل وين رايحه
اهدافكم المعلنه
المزيد من الاستحواذات وباذن الله راح يتم
الاعلان عن استحواذ اخر قريبا في صنف اخر
احنا ما نحاول ننافس بعض
فالمزيد من الاستحواذات واعتقد هذا التوجه
هو عام في كل المنطقه صراحه
عندنا
عام 2023
نعتقد انه
الاستثمار اكثر في البنيه التحتيه الخاصه
فينا ومراكز العمليات راح توسع بشكل كبير
ويمكن اول تحدي راح يكون عندنا الربع
الاول وهو الموسم يعني سواء يعني الاعياد
او يوم الام او غيره يعني من الموجودين
رمضان يعني كذلك
فتوسيع
المراكز العمليات الموجوده عندنا بشكل
كبير
واستعدادات استعداداتنا للطرح العام سواء
كان من جانب قانوني او من جانب تجاري يعني
نحقق اهدافنا الحوكمه شيء انت ذكرته الله
يحفظك فبالفعل احنا
اضفنا كذلك عظمه اداره مستقل موجود معانا
الان
نسعى لزيادته عندنا باذن الله
كذلك اعلان قريب عن جوله استثماريه ان شاء
الله راح نعلن عنه في ليب المؤتمر في
القادم في الشهر شهر فبراير
عندنا الجوانب القانونيه للطرح موضوع
اعاده الهيكله وان شاء الله تكون الشركه
الام كذلك في السعوديه
عندنا
راح نكون اقرب باذن الله للمنتج السعودي
هذا شيء بغايه الضروره وقاعد نشتغل عليه
بشكل يومي ويمكن تحديدا في القهوه
والعسل
والورد الطائفي
والتعاون مع الشركات المحليه يعني احنا
حيل حيل مركزين اننا بناخذ هذه المنتجات
معانا في كل الدول ان شاء الله وتكون مثل
ما تقول مثل السفير للمنتجات السعوديه
وتحديدا هذه الاصناف لانه يمكن اقرب
للمواطن المواطن السعوديين ولو بنسوي
زوماوت نطلع من فلور ونقول المشهد رياده
الاعمال في الخليج يعني انت هنا برجع
لتجربتك اللي صارت في النص بين طلبات وبين
فلاور انت اسست او يعني اشتغلت مع الفريق
على تاسيس كيان معني بتمكير رواد الاعمال
في الكويت وتمويلهم ودعمهم بس ما كانت
تجربه مرضيه لك او او توازي تطلعاتك لما
بديت اليوم في تنافس واضح ومعلن بين
الرياض وبين دبي مع فارق حجم الاقتصاد لكن
ما زالت دبي قادر على انها بعض رؤوس
الاموال بعض رواد الاعمال بعض الجواز
الاستثماريه تتم هناك وان كان احيانا
المؤسس السعودي ورؤساء والسعوديه بس تسجل
لدبي كشركه استقطت هذا الكيان
فبدي اعرف منك قراءتك لمشهد رياده الاعمال
في الخليج
لمن الرياده ايش نقاط القوه والضعف
التجربه الكويتيه رغم انه في رواد اعمال
مميزين جدا جدا خرجوا من الكويت وما زال
يخرجوا من الكويت ليش منظومه الدعم هناك
ما ضبطت معاكم طيب انا اعتقد
ابي ابتدي من من حيث ما بدينا بالاول
الرؤيه تسع الجميع سعودي ولا غير سعودي
وما في احد اليوم من دول الخليج ما يقول
انا ابي اشارك بالرؤيه لنا بالفعل تخدم
اهداف البلد اكس ولا كذلك
اذا بدنا ننطلق من هنا
التنافس حلو
واعتقد يعني يصنع الافضل من نموذج البلد
الفلاني ولا البلد الفلاني وبالنهايه يعني
رواد الاعمال
راح يشتغلون في هذه البلدان كلها وراح
يخدمون وراح يسعون انهم دائما يطورون من
خدماتهم بس اقتصاديا اليوم سواء كان
بالعالم الرقمي او
الاقتصاد التقليدي
السعوديه متميزه صح فهي فعلا اصبحت 50% من
الاقتصاد الرقمي مثل ما بالاقتصاد الناتج
المحلي لا يمكن اهمال ذلك او
يعني تجاهله عدل
فهذا الطبيعي يصير انه السعوديه تصبح قبلت
كل الرواد للاعمال فهذا السباق محسوم من
وجهه نظرك فانا اعتقد كحجم اقتصاد
ما اعتقد هو سباق بقدر ما هو واقع لازم
تتعامل معه الدول ما بين بعض شلون تقدر
التعاون هذا اعتقد راح يحصل وفي الحقيقه
خطوات يعني يمكن احنا طلعنا عليها مجلس
التعاون خليجي موضوع تطوير
التبادل التجاري بشكل عام ما بين المنشات
الخليجيه ان شاء الله راح يحصل اعتقد راح
نشوف المزيد من الاستحواذات تحصل
والاندماجات ما بين الشركات الناشئه
في فجوه بالتمويل بهالجانب هذا تحديدا لان
اليوم شركه في مبيعات حجم فلاورد صعب انها
تقوم في جولات استثماريه
من خلال الصناديق الموجوده حاليا صناديق
الموجوده حاليا منستخدم مراحل اكثر من عمر
الشركات
فاعتقد في فرصه للصناديق هذه انه يكون في
صناديق اكبر تخدم شركات متاخره نقول او
قريبه من الادراج
الجهات الحكوميه في ما بينها وشنو التنافس
ما بين دول الخليج يعني لحسن حظي اطلعت او
يمكن ساهمت بشكل مباشر في بعض الرؤى هذه
اللي كانت موجوده وبحكم عملي في الحكومه
سابقا كنت اشارك بهذه الاشياء وما اعتقد
انهم ترى مختلفين عن بعض كثير
التفاوت في مدى الانجاز الكويت يمكن اليوم
او البحرين او السعوديه او الامارات
التفاوت هذا اعتقد مرتبط في ثقافه العمل
وبيئه العمل في كل السعوديه لو انا بسالك
اليوم بعد الحمام كم مره سمعت كلمه مستهدف
قبل الرؤيه في السعوديه
جدا بينما اليوم هي الفاصله بالجمل ما بين
الناس صح صح كم مره سمعت جوله استثماريه
قبل الرؤيه في السعوديه بحدود يمكن جدا
حتى كلمه جوله مو موجوده صح صح بينما
اليوم وهو
واقعي فاعتقد هذه الثقافه السرعه
ديروقراطيه في احيانا ممكن تعيق العمل بس
وش الاعاقه التجربه بما انك انت عندك
الخبره العمليه عندك الخبره العلميه لانه
الماجستير حقك كان في هذا المجال واعطيت
الادوات واسس الجهاز وتوفر التمويل ليش
النتيجه ما كانت وفق طموحاتك مع انه
الكويت ولاده يعني عشرات المواهب في رياده
الاعمال في قطاعات الاخرى فكل العناصر
موجوده ايش اللي مو قاعد يشتغل هناك
ما تقدر تشتغل في بيئه بمعزل عن بقيه
الجهات الاخرى صح فاليوم اذا كانت الرؤيه
هي توحد عمل كل الجهات وتصب كلها في اتجاه
واحد
اعتقد راح تسهل على كل الجهات اللي هم
يشتغلون مع بعض بينما يمكن في الكويت
وكذلك دول اخرى
البعض يشتغل بعزله عن الاخر وهذه
الجزر
المميزه
متباعده يعني تسبح في
احيانا قد تكون انت قاعد تشتغل وتسوي كل
اللي عليك بس في كثير من الجهات الاخرى
اهدافها مختلفه
رؤى مختلفه فاعتقد هذا السبب الاساسي اللي
هو هني مو بس في رؤيه ومكتوبه على ورق
الناس كلها عايشه هالمشهد هذا وقاعد تساهم
فيه بشكل مباشر غير مباشر
فانا متاكد ان
النبي حصل نفس الشيء في الكويت والبحرين
وعمان ما شاء الله الامارات متميزين وقطر
يعني هو مجرد عامل الوقت متى يحصل بس راح
يحصل ان شاء الله
لما نتكلم احنا على القطاع اللي انتم
شغالين فيه لو اليوم رائد اعمال في بدايات
الرحله وانتم واصلين لمرحله متقدمه في هذا
الرحله
وشهم النقاط اللي بتوصيها فيه على مستوى
سواء السنه هذه 23
صعبه شويه من ناحيه
التمويل التقييم الحصول على الاستثمارات
من ناحيه اختيار الاسواق هل ابدا اثبت
نفسي في سوق اصغر في دول الخليج بعدين
ادخل السوق السعودي ولا ابدا مباشره من
السوق السعودي من وين انطلق في تاسيس
الفريق اي اي توجيهات ترى انها بتكون
مفيده لواحد في بدايه الرحله وش بتقول انا
اعتقد ان
[موسيقى]
مؤشر مهم
وصراحه كان يعني اقلقنا جميعا موضوع الفات
اعلن بالربع الثالث عن كم كان
القيمه المضافه تحصيل الدوله من القيمه
المضاعفه وهي اقل من الماضي مو بس كان اقل
من العام الماضي كان اقل من الربع اللي
قبله فالربع الثاني كان اعلى بكثير من
الربع الثالث قد يكون صيف والناس مو مصدقه
انه بعد تسافر فهذا عامل مهم
واعتقد لازم نكون واعيين له وغالبا ما
عالمنا في الخليج او العالم العربي يكون
يعني متاخر ست شهور الى سنه من اللي قاعد
يحصل في العالم واحنا محنا بمعزل عن
العالم
فالتضخم اللي قاعد يحصل لله الحمد اليوم
دول الخليج يمكن الدوله تدعم كثير من
عناصر التضخم داخل المعادله نفسها بس
معرضين
اعتقد الركود في السوق
ويمكن اول
ربع من السنه
نشعر بان هذا هو الطبيعي ما بعد فيمكن
معدلات المبيعات تضاعفت بشكل كبير بعد
اعتقد اليوم احنا وصلنا
او الطبيعي الجديد كسوق
جولات استثماريه قلت
[موسيقى]
التقايم يمكن رجعت كذلك
لطبيعتها او للارقام المعقوله
راس المال لا زالت موجوده
بس مو قاعده تستثمر الفرص خايفين من
التقييم يرجع يصحح نفسه
[موسيقى]
غالي لكن في كثير من الشركات ما شاء الله
نموذج عملهم اقتصادياتهم ممتازه ولذلك
عندهم النفس انهم كمان ما يعني ما يرضون
باي شيء أدل الشركات اللي اقتصادياتها
كانت مميزه يمكن
تاثرت اقل شيء
مقارنه باللي كان يحرق فلوس كل شهر معدلات
عاليه
والهوامس اللي عنده للربح يعني ضئيله جدا
تكاد تكون منعدمه فهذيل الناس عانوا كثير
واعتقد السوق راح يصفي منهم
بعض الشركات لذلك راح تشوف اندمماده
اندماجات او استحواذات تحصل عليها
بس الناس لازم تحزن بصراحه انا اشوف انه
عام 23 هو مشابه ل22 يمكن وقع راح يكون
اكثر علينا احنا في العالم العربي من
العالم
الغربية
فلازم نكون مستعدين له انت وقفتوا توسع في
هذه السنه وقفنا توسع وبالفعل احنا في
رسالتنا الاخيره للزملاء كان عام
البحث الداخلي اوكي
انا احس هذا كان كشخه
لانه ما دخل في المنطقه اللي تلعبون فيها
وانظمتها وافكارها وشعوبها بشكل سطحي نفس
ما تفضلت لكن الواقع انه فوق ال60% من
عملياتنا اليوميه هي من الخليج فاليوم ابو
عبد الرحمن فلان فلانه ترسل لصديقتها لبنت
خالها من شغلكم في بريطانيا من الخليج من
الخليج في هذا الهدف فهذا الهدف فعلا سد
الف قد يكون نموذج العمل ممكن نلقى شيء
افضل وحاليا قاعد نراجعه وغالبا ما راح
يتغير
فنموذج العمل هناك ممكن يتغير لكن كخدمه
تاكد انه ابدا مو هدفنا منافسه
الكبار اللي موجودين هناك في السوق بس
المبدا اللي كنا نسولف فيه انه سنه 23
لرواد الاعمال هي فرصه انك انت تمسك امورك
بشكل افضل طول الرنوي او تزيد فتره
يعني استخدام السيول المتوفره اذا كنت انت
معتمد على جولات فاذا كانت الجوله تمشيك
عشر شهر خليها توصلك 18 20 قد ما تقدر
لانها سلاح تكون يعني مو سهله مو سهله مو
سهله وخصوصا السوق يعني في عوامل داخليه
عندك وتقدر انت ديرها تخلص عدد الموظفين
او تسرح فلان علان تغير نموذج العمل بس في
عوامل خارج ارادتك اللي هي السوق
والسوق انا اعتقد يعني واصل مرحله ركود مو
ما تقدر تاخذ حصه اكبر من السوق وهذا اللي
المفروض الوالد اعمال نسويه يعني لكن
نمو طبيعي ما اعتقد انه راح نشوف كثير
اتذكر في تدوين عبد الرحمن ابو مالح 2016
مع انطلاق رؤيه كان يتكلم على انه وحده من
ابرز التحديات الموجوده هو موضوع
المدفوعات ونقل عن مازن الضراب
حوار صار بين مازن وبين جيف بيزوس مؤسسه
امازون وساله ليش ما دخلتوا السوق السعودي
او الاسواق العربيه بشكل عام قال اصلح
المدفوعات وكل شيء يصلح بعدها نعم وكان
الكلام وقتها على انه 75% من التجاره
الالكترونيه في السعوديه
الدفع كاش نعم نعم اليوم كم نسبه
المدفوعات الكاش من مبيعات فلورت في
السعوديه
صفر ما نقبل الكاش عجيب فكل مبيعاتكم هي
عباره عن مدفوعات رقميه يعني اللهم اذا
كان عندنا تعامل مع بعض الشركات الخاصه
لما يطلبون شيء خاص لمجموعه فاليوم الدفع
عن طريق الكاش غير متوفر اوكي وامو لان
احنا ما نبي نوفره بقدر ما هو السوق تطور
وهذا احد الاشياء اللي ذكرناها قبل شوي
كابني تحتيه مدفوعه الرقميه تطورت بشكل
ملحوظ جدا صارت اسهل بكثير عدل
اعتقد السوق يستوعب فعلا قد يكون في بعض
المنتجات لا زالت
يفضلها العميل
انا اشوف احيانا لا زال في موضوع
الكاشون دليفري الكاش نفسه موجود في بعض
الاصناف مو كلها بس السواد الاعظم بس انتم
مئه في المئه مدفعة رقميه
في تغريد الحاكم كاملي في مايو 2020 يقول
الانترنت في السعوديه تطور الشراء تطور
المتاجر تطورت المدفوعات رقم تطورت
الاستثمارات اللي داخله قطاع الطورت كل
شيء تطور الا الخدمات ما زالت هي نقطه
الالم يعني بتصرف انقل تغريده بتصرف تتفق
معه متى هذا الله يحفظك في مايو 2020
اعتقد يمكن يكون بذاك الوقت فعلا كان في
بعض التحديات بس على الاقل اليوم في المدن
الكبيره في السعوديه ما اعتقد هذا التحدي
موجود للعمليات
البسيطه يعني اذا اليوم احد بيفتح له موقع
ومتجر الالكتروني ويخدم
في نمو في تزايد ما اعتقد هذه المشكله
تواجه السعوديه الان اذا لا والله انت
شغال وعلى
خلينا نقول نمو اكثر من
البدايات
اعتقد لازال في فرصه انه يتطور بالفعل
كابن يعني
ارقام صغيره ما في مشاكل من تكبر اعتقد في
فرصه انه يتطورنا
ومتى نوصل لمرحله يعني هل تواجهون مشكله
اليوم في مساله العنونه وهل هي عامه ولا
بس في السعوديه يعني ما زال اليوم ارسال
واتساب فجاه تطب عليك انا مندوب من فلور
اعطني لوكيشن بيتك بالفعل بس في السعوديه
ولا كل الاسواق العربيه تواجهونها احنا
سلمك الله حاولنا نسهل على الناس لان كثير
تعرف الطلب مو خاص في عمر مو خاص بعبد
العزيز لما يطلبون
انا طالب لشخص صحيح ابي ارسل له هديه
فغالبا ما اعرف عنوانه وما نبي نعطل خدمتك
فعشان هالشي صار في عندك نفس الميزه او
خدمه ان تاخذ العنوان من العميل وهذا يتم
بشكل الاوتوماتيكي عبر الرسائل نفس ما
تفضلت تاخذ العنوان والعميل من المستلم من
المرسل المستلم يعني فعشان كذا حاولنا
بقدر المستطاع ان اتمت هذه العمليه سبحان
الله صار صارت الرساله هذه ثقافيا عند
المجتمع وهنا نلمسها كثير
على طول واحد من توصل له يحط
بالسوشيال ميديا مواقع التواصل يلا صباح
الخير هذا الصباح ولا بلاش فصارت كانها
حاله حلوه صراحه بالمجتمع واحنا محظوظين
اننا نشتغل فعلا باسعاد الاخرين على طريق
سعاد الاخرين كم في المئه من من مبيعاتكم
اعمال خيريه قرابه الواحد بالمئه واحد في
المئه انتم التزام داخلي من البدايه من
يوم بديته واحد في المئه
ولا اقصد جزء من الورد البايت تودونه
الجمعيات ولا مئه في المئه من الكاش اللي
دخل يروح مع الخيريه اول شيء ما في ورد
بايت يستخدم لاي غرض اوكي معنا
احنا مصطلحي صحيح ترى
وما نستعمله فاحنا عندنا زملائنا في
امريكا الجنوبيه وفي افريقيا دورهم كل يوم
انهم يختارون لنا احسن انواع الورود
من هذه المناطق وبعدين يرسلونها لنا ونفس
الشيء على مستوى محلي الروح والله مزرعه
فلان نروح بالطائف الورد الطائفي كذا
فهدفنا دائما نوفر احسن
[موسيقى]
جوده في الورود اللي نقدمها العمل الخيري
الله يحفظك
اشكاله مختلفه فممكن اليوم عمل احنا
بالتعاون والله ما الامانه في الرياض نبي
نوزع اطلاقات ورود على
الناس بمناسبه يوم التاسيس
هذا جزء من التزام اتجاه المجتمع احيانا
يكون كاش ولا في بعض الاسر اللي محتاجه
ترميم بيوتها
وحاشهم سيل ولا مطر ومساكين يغرقه وفنروح
نعاونهم احيانا في بعض الاسر اللي عيالهم
مميزين ما شاء الله لكن ما يقدرون يوفرون
الماده عندهم انه يكملون تحصيلهم العلمي
احيانا بالروح لبعض المدارس وبنشارك يوم
المعلم ان الطالب يهدي المعلمه والمعلمه
باقه ورد فهي مزيج ما بين سواء كان ورود
عينيه او نقديه نقدمها
انا بدي يعني
اختم هذا الحوار باني اسالك ابو بدر
انت انت اول ضيف في سقراط غير سعودي وان
كان يعني الخليجيين الكويتين يعني نعتبرهم
انه فينا بس نقصد انه اول ضيف يحكي عن
الرؤيه من خارج السعوديه
فلو في مستمعين اليوم قاعدين يستمعوا لنا
يبغون يسمعون وجهه نظر محايده من خارج
الدائره المستفيدين او المتاثرين باللي
قاعد يحصل في السعوديه فكيف كيف تصف
بموضوعيه اللي صار في الخمس سنوات الماضيه
له يبغى يسمع من طرف محايد او طرف من خارج
ايش اللي صار في السعوديه في نهايه السنه
الماضيه وصراحه عده مرات اهدي بعض الكتب
حق بعض الاصدقاء او بعض المسؤولين بالدوله
في السعوديه
اخرها كان نهايه السنه
او كتبت له
ان الله بالخير
بفلان
لم ارى همه وروح تشبه حاله السعوديه اليوم
في حياتي لتكن هذه الهمه والروح دائما
محله لقائنا اراك هناك وبالفعل انا اعتقد
ان
الحاله العامه في الدوله يمكن البدايات
بدايه الرؤيه كان في
ممكن
يعني
رؤيه طموحه وان شاء الله يا رب يقدرنا انا
اعتقد الحاله العامه بالدوله احنا بنتسابق
مع انفسنا وهذه الرؤيه ما قامت تلبي
طموحنا والرؤيه بنفسها قاعد تجدد نفسها
وتجدد نفسها مره اخرى
فاعتقد الحاله العامه للدوله هناك في شعور
بالعزه والفخر والانتماء وروح عاليه
لتطوير البلد وايا كان نشاطك او نشاط
البنت
في متسع للجميع انه يتطور
ثقافه اعتقد في الدوله
تطورت بشكل كبير انا اعتقد بشكل ايجابي
وبالفعل اصبح
اصبحت الرؤيه تسع الجميع فهي ما هي محصوره
فقط على السعوديين وانا اول الناس اللي
يعتقد
استفدت من من التطور والتغير اللي حصل
واعتقد هناك الكثيرين الرؤيه اعتقد هي
ساهمت بشكل مباشر بوضع السعوديه في
مكانتها الطبيعيه
وان شاء الله للافضل
واعتقد انها فعلا قبلت كل رواد الاعمال
ونقتبس كلام الامير محمد في مؤتمر الايفاي
2018 لما كان يقول انه في التسعينات
ظهر شخصيه في العالم العربي باحدث حراك
الهم كثيرين واكد لهم اننا نستطيع اللي هو
كان يذكر الشيخ حمد بن راشد في دبي
فاذا كانت قصه دبي تركت هذا الاثر
فان شاء الله تعالى قصه السعوديه وقصص
جميع دول الخليج وعام عربي تترك اثر من
الالهام والامل على البقيه لانه ما عندنا
شيء نقصنا غير الاراده واليوم الاراده
موجوده اما البقيه فهي تحصيل حاصل وبمثل
قصصكم وقصص الاخرين ان شاء الله نقدر
نقف في مكاننا الطبيعي في صداره الامم
ونترك اثرنا في هالبشريه زي ما كانوا
اسلافنا من قبل شكرا لكم ابو بدر ممتن جدا
لق الدعوه وشرفتونا ونورتنا الله يعزك بس
في بيت لحم مطر يقول انا وحدي يا دوله ما
دام عندي الامل دوله انقى وارقى حين تفنى
كل الدول شكرا لك ابو عبد الرحمن شكرا
لثمانيه وشكرا لضيوفك الكرام الله يحييك
تسلم شكرا لكم شكرا فهداك صغير في اعداد
وانتاج الحلقه ياسر الغانم وياسر كذا شغل
في الكاميرات وفي تسجيل الصوت عبد العزيز
المزي وفي التحرير محمد الديني وفي
الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي الاشراف
على الانتاج رزان الدهيثم هذا بودكاست احد
منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]